well thank you very dense for the
deduction and invitation to be here I
think the last time I gave a lecture at
Stanford was something in the 90s and so
it's always a pleasure and great honor
to be to this university I so the story
I want to tell you has been around for a
while and and actually quite a few
YouTube versions of earlier versions of
this talk I don't know how many how many
of you have seen it or heard about it
but I promise some new things here now
this is a colloquium so I have to be
clear to everyone first of all that this
is as you see from the title that there
are essentially two themes there one is
information theory and the other one is
learning or in particular much called
deep deep neural networks and in between
there is this button like which I'm
going to describe but essentially as you
may know I mean deep learning is is one
of those things that changed the world I
think we can say it today without
exaggerating too much and so so neural
networks have been around for a long
time the idea it's starting actually in
the 40s with the AI formal idea of a
neuron as this what we call the
McCulloch pitts neuron which is
essentially just this gate which is to
take a dot product of some weights by
some inputs and then pass them through
some sort of non-linearity which
originally was just a sine function and
then was softened to some sort of a
sigmoid function and then today we are
using all sorts of other function mostly
what we call values essentially of just
rectified linear rectifiers now the idea
of actually putting them in networks
with many layers is quite old of it goes
all the way to the 50s and through the
work of Frank Rosenblatt essentially who
suggested also tender the notion
perceptron or multi-layer perceptron and
this was essentially when you look at
his book from 1959 or something like
that
see it has all of all the story in it I
mean the idea of actually putting many
layers of these nonlinear special
functions connected to each other as
some sort of a pattern recognition
system nobody was talking about learning
then but is there but this was ruled out
as not practical in the standards of the
60s and 70s having too many parameters
highly nonlinear impossible to train
because you're going to get rough in
local optima all the good stories that
we all know how to tell our students
that too many parameters it's not going
to work and it was essentially ruled out
in a very in a very bright brilliant
book by a remote area of Minsky and
Papert two really important names in the
story of history I and who gave us all
day completely rigorously by the way all
the good reasons why it will never work
now it came back in the 80s and through
what we now call the the connection is
an area era and the when I actually got
interested in these things after
finishing my PhD in physics in in on
aerodynamics actually and then I I went
into this story of physics of neural
networks which emerge actually from the
hopfield model and a few other things
that came in the early eighties 82 both
the formal definition of machine
learning through the work of Ellis
valiant just later on connected with the
works of buttnik and other Russians then
who were there even before and it was
actually buttnik who killed the idea at
the end of the 80s and early 90s and by
essentially introducing this notion of
kernel methods and support vector
machines which are some sort of neural
networks but they are simpler and much
easier to analyze and proof things about
them and for about a decade they really
dominated the machine learning field in
the 90s during the late eighties by the
way some physicists including me started
to do something which we then call
statistical physics of neural networks
which is essentially analyzing
large-scale diamond in the thermodynamic
limits in some sense networks like this
but what we could do is really show off
our mathematical techniques on a very
simple toy problems like one layer
perceptron in some cases two layers this
three layer system we couldn't really do
anything interesting those using these
methods and of course the whole idea of
using this large-scale statistical
physics went wasn't essentially didn't
leave a mark I mean it was unnoticed
after if some physicists still like it
but it's didn't make any big difference
on the machine learning community at
least but then during the last decade
and since the late 2000 2006 seven eight
nine and a certain group of people I'm
sure you all know about them Geoff
Hinton
Ian lacunae and a few others essentially
pushed the idea of neural networks to
what they called on we call now deep
neural networks my adding many many
layers and the number and of course it's
not only the number of layers it's the
size of the problem the size of the
input which grew up by three orders of
magnitude sometimes more for I mean so
we moved from from inputs of the size of
hundreds as a pixels of an image or
something like this to megapixels or
sometimes more and we are now talking
about problem which are really loud
scream and and and with it came this big
surprise and at around two thousand
seven eight-nine those deep system
different networks is a lot of layers
started to beat all the previous
technologies in competitions on image
recognition object recognition speech
recognition a lot of other problems in
signal processing later on in control in
networks with feedbacks and so on
essentially they took over almost
everything we used to call AI I mean
both vision speech natural language
processing playing go playing Atari
games whatever you want essentially
whatever you want it's really very
surprising because it's essentially the
same architecture
many layers of these non linear
threshold gates which are which
essentially somehow miraculously solve
many different problems and of course
they're also inspired by the brain in
various ways I mean we called them
neural networks because there's some
sort of resembles of analogy with the
way we understand the neural system but
the resemblance is very weak at best so
the question this was actually very bad
news for traditions of people like me we
really try to understand and why these
things work so well and so III I'm going
to start slowly because I'm going to
just lay the foundation but so what
during the last five years essentially
together with two students whose name
was mentioned there and no galovski and
which was even both brain science
students actually in jerusalem and we
started to explore the connection which
was something which means something
which i have essentially thought of in
the 80s in the context of speech
recognition I mean a principle the
information theoretic way of extracting
relevant small dimensional relevant
variables from large complex data which
later in the 90s we call the information
button like matter I come back to this
and I had a very strong feeling that
this is the right theory or the right
way of understanding why this deep
neural networks work and of course this
was largely ignored as well for a while
but then we start to do some experiments
and and some simulation in ourselves to
give some talks which are on YouTube and
in the last year the whole thing you
know there was some sort of face elation
everybody somehow see this picture and I
am invited to many places grants fund
some food to talk about it so so this is
something which for me was a it was very
very nice but quite a big surprise so
what is really there this story so it
turns out that we we are really
combining three different ingredients
which in a sense change the paradigm a
first of all about learning theory
so in learning theory which is what I
call rethinking learning theory we
actually move from what we used to call
distribution independent bound of the
type of the
the probably approximately correct the
model of Valiant which essentially gives
you bound on generalization error which
are independent of the distribution
which means independent of the problem
but are very strongly dependent on the
architecture or what we usually call the
hypothesis class I mean what type of
functions my machine or my algorithm can
generate so we move from these to a
different type of of bounds which are
actually strongly sensitive to the
problem the problem dependent their
distribution dependent but they're much
less sensitive to the architecture so
III moved the universality from the the
problem of the distributional problem to
the architecture of the slam chased by
time so from worst case distribution
dependent results we moved to typical
case distribution dependent but
architecture independent result and I
believe that this is very important for
this type of machines the worst-case
analysis doesn't mean seem to get us
anywhere yes I do by actually using all
the ideas that are just rethinking about
information theory of the shanno's
communication theory in a slightly
different way so using the same
techniques or the same mathematics that
is used in information theory which is
the notion of typical sequences or
typicality of very large patterns I'm
reusing it but the typicality here is
not in time but actually let's say in
the patches of the images that we train
or in pieces of speech or whatever the
signal is I take into account the fact
that it's really big now because it's
really big we can use those typical
average arguments and actually get very
precise results so this is the way I
information theory comes into the game
what information theory is not going to
tell us much about the most important
aspect of this question of deep neural
networks which is that the the fact that
we actually can train it effectively in
finite time I mean in hours or days or
weeks but not in tens of years on our
computers today which means that there's
something that scales and very nicely
with the size of the problem without
paying
financially long times now so time is a
different issue which is really the
computational aspects and it's not going
to be answered by information theoretic
ideas because information measures our
environment to computational complexity
in a very profound sense so way what
what come then the third ingredient here
is really these stochastic dynamics of
the training algorithms were using which
is what we call stochastic gradient
descent or back propagation or error
back propagation or all these kind of
things that we are using for deep neural
networks and those algorithms turn out
to be not so stupid as we use the thing
I mean this is exactly what Minsky and
Papert told us is never going to work
actually they work miraculously well and
any attempt to improve them let's say
from by moving to things like
second-order methods or methods which
are not just now sliding a lot of the
gradient or in a noisy version of the
gradient tend to usually don't work well
actually don't work at all with this
type of large problems so the question
is why so I'm actually going to connect
all this rain in three things all right
let me skip this so essentially the idea
is is simple and I just want to
establish a few facts it and I apologize
for those of you who may have seen it
elsewhere so I'm I'm going to think
about the neural network remember this
is each one of those circles is is a
neuron which means a linear threshold
gate which and now think about the input
layer let's say pixels of an image or
something like this as a very high
entropy variable a very high dimensional
variable which I call which I call X and
think about the labels and I'm not
talking about the simplest possible form
of deep learning which is supervised
learning I'm showing the images and give
let's say is it you or not you or is it
a face or is it a car or is it a dog or
a cat oh very simple classification
problems now this so I can actually
think it's why the desired label is a
very simple variable which can be only
just one bit anyway it's a lot simpler
than X okay the problem is that this one
bit is not encoded in any simple way in
the image there's no one pixel or one
bit in the image that tells me this it's
highly distributed if that's the so what
what actually happens in neural network
is that this input or this first layer
is now going through a transformation of
layers and each one of them is a new
representation of my image and just by
thinking looking at it you see that
there is a Markov chain of
representations here so each
representation can be calculate only
from the previous one and affects only
the next one so the story I want to
understand is what's actually going on
through this a representation
transformation of this cascade of
representation changes now before I go I
must I must introduce some quantities
which I'm sure if you are mostly in
electrical engineers you all know them
so so I need some information measures
and in particular I need the notion of
mutual information so how many of you
don't need it know what mutual
information is not that may owe you
don't dare to say that you knew that's
stranger okay
so way so I need two quantities one of
them is known as the KL divergence or
the cross entropy or the information
divergence has many different names and
this is this averaged log likelihood of
two distributions so I have P and Q over
some random variable take the log of the
ratio and average respect to the first
one
this quantity is non-negative it's zero
precisely when you're equal almost
everywhere and and it's a very
fundamental quantity which has I can
teach a whole course about why it's
important so many different ways but
anybody know something about statistical
hypothesis testing for example know that
the log lie feel ratio is a very
important thing and and they and the
average of it is really telling us a lot
about the rate of achieving making
decisions and so many other things for
the has entirely different ways and
meanings information theory the mutual
information which I need all of you to
to appreciate and know at this point is
the KL divergence between the Joint
Distribution of two variables and the
product of the marginals and it's going
to be zero precisely when the two
variables are independent
the joint is the product and then and
otherwise it's a non-negative quantity
which can be interpreted as the entropy
or the uncertainty in the variable X -
now answer to be removed from X when I
know why this is a symmetric on T thing
and it's actually going to be very
important for us because I'm actually
going to from now hold on I'm going to
look at mutual information quantities in
my neural networks all over the place
now there are two things about mutual
information that I want you to
appreciate one of them is known as the
data processing inequality which means
that if I'm moving along a Markov chain
let's say X Y Z in this case and then
information can only decrease this is
true not only finished information so
for a whole range of other measures like
this but there's something very special
about new information which is uniquely
determined not only the person quality
it has another another property which I
need which we usually call the mean mean
is minimizer I'm going to need it about
I'm going to talk about now so first an
immediate consequence of the dpr data
processing in equality is that under any
invertible maps of x and y the
information doesn't change so this is
actually the bad news for anybody was
trying to use information for
computational complexity because it
means that i can encrypt my i can take
any any hard transformation how to
invert information of my data this is
not going to affect information measures
but it's going to create a big headache
in terms of the computational complexity
so information is not telling us
anything about computational complexity
but now as i look at it my at my new
neural networks there is immediately a
chain of inequalities which i want to
call the information path which is
essentially how much information is
there it layer one about the input how
much information is there about layer in
layer two about the input and because
it's a Markov chain of transformations
information can only decrease about the
input and if i ask the same about the
desired output remember I'm talking
about generalization about what the
label should be not what the label is at
the end of the network and this is also
decreasing when I go through the layers
so I have these two chains of inequality
which I'm going to call the information
paths of a network like this and
essentially what you should appreciate
that only this Markov chain of of layers
is essentially inducing some sort of
partitioning which of the data so think
about all the images that are met to the
same same value of the layer the same
representation of the units and and and
this partition can only get closer when
I move from one layer to the next so
there's some sort of questioning of the
representation so this is an information
theory this is related to something we
call successful refinement I'm going to
come back to this at the end and and but
notice that of course I can scramble or
the network can scramble my
representation in an arbitrary way and
this will not affect those information
regions ok so another slightly different
way of thinking about it is to think
about each layer as being encoded by a
some sort so there's a a meta stochastic
map in general from the input to the
layer here I call it t it was the same
thing so any any layer T t1 t2 t3 any
one of those hidden layers is actually
mapped and met from the input which I
call the encoder of the layer and and so
any layer has an encoder which is how it
is mapped from the input both have maps
it generates and there is a decoder
which is the the way I'm trying to
extract the label of the desired level
there this is the label I'm I'm actually
training I call it Y hat here because
they're not exactly why this what this
is what the network is generating and
during the training two things happen
first of all I'm trying to push y hat to
be as close as possible to Y then I said
that the network is working will and the
other thing is that when you move from
one layer to the next the encoder
becomes more and more complicated the
first time code and the first encoder is
very simple and but the decoder is very
complicated when you it and then then
code they become more more complicated
and the decoder becomes simpler at the
last hidden layer the decoder is
essentially just a linear social
function was just a perceptron just one
layer position ok so the question is how
is this miracle happens that somehow
from layer to layer I
more information by the encoder and
eventually get to a very simple decoder
and now I actually here is a very
informal formulation of a theorem which
we now have a much clearer formulation
and I I dare to say that essentially the
only two numbers out of those zillion of
parameters and that are really important
for each layer and this is the mutual
information of the encoder and the
mutual information of the decoder
essentially the mutual information of
the desired output given the layer and I
am you that if you know these two
numbers for each layer and in particular
for the last hidden layer we we can
predict both the two things you really
care about which are the accuracy the
probability of making an error outside
of my training data what we call the
generalization error and the number of
samples of what we call the sample
complexity so the trade-off within
complexity of the samples how many data
a I really need and what accuracy this
is going to give me it's going to depend
for large enough problems where I can
use typicality arguments and for large
enough networks such that they can
actually learn this rule if you have to
depend only on these two quantities the
information of the encoding information
on the decoder so this is quite
remarkable because it's going to
simplify the problem dramatically if you
actually believe me then I don't need to
know anything about everything else
architecture is not so important I need
to know only what is how much
information there is in the encoder of
the decoder of delays now this is what I
call the information plan sometimes we
call it the there so these two
coordinates the information about the
input versus the information about the
output of the desired output are going
to tell us a very interesting story so
in order to see this I I'm going to use
this movie that some of you may have
seen but it's always very important to
see it again so what you see here are
these two axis that the x-axis is the
information that each of the layer has
about the input the y-axis is the
information that this layer has about
the output and the colors represent
layers of a specific neural network
which I trained hundred times with
different random initial country
and different training data and I change
both the sample size it's the same size
but different selection of the sample
and and oh and the ordering of the
examples because there are it's a
stochastic gradient descent which I'm
going to change so other than that I am
now training this deep neural networks
in the most plain vanila using tens of
flow or something like this a way like
everybody else and what we want to see
is how those information values evolve
in time through the efforts of training
so what you see now is the initial
condition of the network so right up
here in blue is my first hidden layer
this first hidden layer essentially
maintained even with random
initialization all the almost all the
information about both the input in the
output that's why it's hid so this is
the first hidden layer the one closer
closest to the input and the last hidden
layer this one day in orange is the the
last layer which is supposed to learn
you see that the initial condition they
know very little about both the input
and the output so they're in the left
left down corner now this is the initial
condition what happens when you start
training it with this big with
stochastic gradient descent and so this
is the this is usually the picture which
works up everyone so essentially what
happens and as you see there the number
of epochs running up there so you see it
was very fast so I'll I'll do it I'll
move it slowly so it's actually up to
this point up to this point which is
about 300 epochs of training so what we
call epoch of training essentially
cycling of all the examples in
mini-batches and the way we calculate
the grad and in stochastic gradient
descent is we don't calculate the
gradient over all the examples we
actually cut the examples into small
sets which we call mini batch which can
be hundred of 200 or 300 examples and
and we calculate this noisy version of
the gradient and we update the weights
for each one of those many batches so
any update of the weights through all
the many batches what we call
so after 300 epochs which means 300
cycles of cycling of the data through my
networks we get more or less to this
point which is interesting so first of
all you see the data processing
inequality you see that the information
goes down as you expect actually this
points are almost linearly down and you
see there are actually six hidden layers
the reason you see these clouds is
because as I said we repeated the
experiments hundred times with random
initial conditions but so up to this
point around 300 epochs all the networks
that the older layers went up which
means they improve increase the
information about the label but also to
the left to the right which means they
also acquired more information about the
input all of them all the layers
together and from this point on
something interesting happen it starts
very very slowly I'm sorry
and it's very very slowly moving to the
left and up and if you look at the
number of epochs out of this about 90
10000 epochs only 300 which is very
little it took to get to that to this
same middle point which I argue is a
very important point this is where the
data the training error essentially is
saturated now it's very small this is
what we all believe is the most
important part of training fitting the
labels of the data but this happens very
quickly after around 300 a box and then
the rest 10000 - 300 epochs essentially
slowly moving by what I'm going to call
diffusion or by by the noise in the
gradients of course there's Tim Robbins
there's still something that pushing you
down but it's dominated by by the noise
in the gradient that's what I'm going to
show you well it's slower relative to
the faster I mean it's 10000 epochs no
no everything will be clear there ok ok
I hope not everything but some things ok
so so so there are these two - what I
call phases of learning in the first one
you feed the data in the set
then you do this very irritably slow I
mean it's ten or a hundred times slower
than the first place where you move to
the left and I call it the forgetting
phase of the learning now you're already
going to give you the gist of the story
during the first part of the learning
you actually fit the labels you do this
what we call empirical risk minimization
we should consider the holy grail of
learning for many many years this is
what we want to do but it's actually the
second part which is done when the error
is essentially fluctuating I mean it's
not zero but it's moving up and down
between those mini epochs which are
subsets of the training data during this
phase which is not supposed to do much
according to the classical theories most
of the improvement in my information
about the label happens and this is
strange
I mean to surprise an explanation and my
story is that the gist of it is at this
phase we actually forget or learn to
ignore the irrelevant details of the
patterns those things which are not
labeled the changes the differences in
the background the fact that there are
so many dimensions of the problem
which are not important for the label so
that's the hard part
ignoring or forgetting or learning to
ignore the irrelevant details of the
program now so the rest of the story is
just trying to justify what I just told
you based on some other analysis yes yes
I'm going to tell you okay this is the
story so anyway so so the this was some
of you know a mystery story attracted
the quanta magazine the attention wander
magazine this is a nice picture that
they gave for this so what you actually
there are several other questions I
wanted to ask before going to this so
what just looking at this create this
picture first of all you want to ask is
this the general picture or maybe just
this is a special case with a very
special network and a very small problem
and so on so believe me we see this
precisely the same story for very large
problems or at least as large as we
could different the second question that
usually people ask how do you estimate
new information okay
so we estimate mutual information using
in this case very small problem and
we've been the data for last problems
use a much more sophisticated methods
all sorts of parametric representation
like Gaussian mixture models on each one
of the layers we know how to do it if
you do it's wrong you don't see this
picture actually that's a very nice
paper came from Harvard they are lucky
at taking us precisely on this this is
not the issue now so we see note the
second question is which is list for me
was very interesting
among these hundred points why do they
concentrate them and why do you get this
relatively concentrated the point I mean
so this requires an explanation I mean
these are entirely different networks if
you actually compare the weights then no
correlation they look very different or
you're compared to even the values of
the neurons there are not they're not
correlated but the in value of the
information turned out to be very very
sharp and it gets sharper the larger the
prominent this is precisely what we like
when things get concentrated in the
large limit then we know that we have
what we call good order parameters now
the third question is ok what do these
numbers mean
I mean why they are interesting so I
already told you that the y-axis is
going to dominate the generalization
error the higher the information about
the label the smaller the error and this
is a rigorous nature it's not an
approximate statement we can prove it
and it gets tighter and tighter bound
when you get to a larger prominence
again the second x-axis or the amount of
what I call compression I mean how much
I forget the input in bits is precisely
going to dominate the general the number
of examples in it or the sample
complexity so this is why this is this
is the theorem that I mentioned some
it's some sort of a coding theorem
because it's relating informational
quantities those entropic like functions
to really things we care about like code
lengths or arrows or in this case
generation error and number of examples
that's why this is in the flavor and the
spirit of both be like and love about
information theory now so say the cell
of course in the most at the last
question e which is the most fascinate
one is what governs that this strange
dynamics I mean why does it move so
quickly first and so slowly later and
one that why does it compress so I want
to answer all these questions to you of
course not
completely as much as I can with so
again because they concentrate we can
average those subject to reason and this
is the simple version of the story I now
average those points and you get it is
very nice to Dexter we from A to C I
remember I fit the data from C to e I
generalize and it happens that all the
layers are doing this type of story more
or less together and they all come to
this inflection point point C more or
less together okay so why what is the
story now I hesitate to give you this
proof again because it takes time and
it's rough I mean it's not it's not as
rigorous as I would like it to me but I
just want to give you the gist of it as
we like to say so those of you who know
something about learning theory I hope
all of you know something about learning
theory should be familiar with what we
call the old
what I call the old the type of him
generalization and let me eliminate
account so the old type of generation
bar looks like that this type of bound
on on the on the on the left which is
essentially and let me just magnify so
this is a the generation error which is
this epsilon which is again the
probability of making an error on my new
unseen data out of my training it's
bounded by essentially two terms the
number of examples which is in the
denominator which okay then larger the
number of samples I've seen the smaller
there but on the on the numerator which
is the important term is the log of the
cardinality of my hypothesis class this
is valiant and this is beautiful because
it gives us bound which is completely
independent anything except these two
numbers of course this this log 1 over
Delta which is what we call the
confidence and the confidence is this
the probability of seeing a very bad
sample ok the probability of saying a
very bad sample is 0 when you talk about
million images
when once once you move to very large
data this is completely negligible for
small problem is important but we still
keep it there
the I mean log of over Delta think of
Delta is ten to the minus ten or
something like this
so this is ten okay but we're talking
millions of examples for log of age and
M of order of millions now so it's the
competition between the log of the
cardinality of the of the hypothesis
class and the number of examples one of
is controlling the complexity of my
learning the other one is controlling
the data actually gained from the data
and of course what we usually do is we
we we want to work with the infinite
classes so we approximate and we cover
the hypothesis class which is usually
infinite like you know rectangular
things like this by what we call epsilon
grid or epsilon quantization which are
essentially cover it with a finite
number of points which are not more than
epsilon might pass on any other episode
and find a grid like this an epsilon net
also agreed now usually if you have a
finite dimensional system a class then
we can cover it the number the size of
the cover
grows like one over epsilon to the
dimension of the class this is geometry
so this can be the house of dimension or
the fractal dimension or the or the VC
dimension or the shattering dimension
with that many different types of
dimension likely they all behave like
this eventually when you need that that
advanced cover the side of the cover
grow exponentially with the dimension so
if we plug this here and this is really
the miracle of a of the VC Theory you
plug this in the first the first time
you get the D over the number of example
is the dominus factor once the number of
examples is is larger than d your
sentries begin to generalize the
dimension as long as it's smaller than D
you don't generalize this doesn't mean
anything this is beautiful we were have
been working with this for 30 years now
there are many books in them but the
problem is that we all know although
some don't admit these bounds don't give
us anything
they're vacuous for deep learning which
means that any
reasonable estimate of the
dimensionality of the class gave us
something which off the order of the
number of weights may be the square root
of the number of weights may be the
weights log the number of weight or
something like this but it's the number
of weight the band depending on how you
exactly count it which is millions or
actually hundreds of millions or
billions today where as the number of
examples okay some of them Google told
me that they are doing costs of billions
of examples but then they're talking
about hundreds of billions of parameters
so there's a there are at least two or
300 order of magnitudes between the
number of examples and the
dimensionality estimated any reasonable
way of determining things now this is a
telling to meet me at least this is not
the right theory I mean it doesn't work
of course there's a lot of good clever
people who are trying to estimate the
dimensionality and to show you that this
known F is actually very expressive that
they can express extremely complicated
function which is cause true but this
doesn't explain why they are performing
so well with so little data
there must be something which regularize
the problem in a very profound way so
what what I'm sure I'm saying is
actually it's the essence of e instead
of covering the hypothesis class let's
quantize the input so this is a gate for
engineers this is a very very well-known
story because this is exactly what we do
in sampling instead think about the
Nyquist limit about the been limited
functions we actually in order to
estimate the function we need it we need
to know it in very small number of
points I mean it was only in the Indian
IQ surfacing so most of the point we
actually actually don't don't know the
value and still we estimate the function
pretty well from samples okay because
because the sample functions are cluster
Abell in some sense so the general the
general notion here is take the class of
patterns X and cover it by sphere so X
here this ellipse blue ellipse is all my
patterns all the images that I care
about and now imagine that I can group
them or cluster them somehow in a
partition this data into cells which are
essentially homogeneous with respect to
the label which means that the
probability of having the wrong label
in each cell is smaller than epsilon how
I get it this is different story but
let's say that I gave you this partition
then I know that the number that the
number of functions go from as a boolean
function from 2 to the cardinality of X
to 2 to the graph of the partition now
ok so so this doesn't look like a very
dramatic things but now I go to
information theory and again I'm going
to skip all the notion of typicality do
I need to remind you what it is
ok so so we are talking about typical
patterns no and I actually need it and
this is where the heart of information
theory comes into the story typical
patterns are patterns where the
probability of a pattern can be
approximately factorized into men it
products a long product of conditionally
independent terms so this is the story
let's say with hidden Markov models or
with Markov random fields or with the
Bayesian networks with some finite
degree or with a physical system with
Hamiltonian with finite interaction and
so many other systems that we know that
essentially the distribution can be
written as a product or approximately
asymptotically as a product dominated by
single program in this case the log of
the probability is going to approach a
limit and this limit is known as the
general McMillan entropy so if and this
is of course the limiting probability
but we know that if such limits exist
the system has has a well-defined
entropy and at the same time almost all
the patterns because this is going to
concentrate to this limit due to the
central limit theorem eventually when n
is large enough most of the patterns are
going to be very close to this limit
which means that most of the patterns
are going to have the same probability
and this is a property we called
information theory asymptotic
equipartition I think this name is
actually due to some cover but I'm not
sure so so it's a it's a it's a it's
this particular number which tells us
all typical patterns not only most
almost all patterns are going to be
typical book all of all of them are
going to be essentially equally likely
which means that the size of the the
number of typical patterns is actually 1
over this probability which is 2
to the entropy okay so this is the the
fundamental trick that is used in
information theory in both source coding
and chunker and there and I'm going to
assume as that my partition is such that
the pattern associate which each of
these cell is are also typical so this
is again I divided my inputs into cells
very the same way that I divided the
glass of water into little drops which
are all in equilibrium and in the same
trick exactly this works in statistical
physics works here and in that sense I
assume not only that the pattern itself
is difficult but the conditional on the
partition is also typical so I can write
it as 2 to the minus conditional entropy
now this is as I said this is where it's
a very familiar trick but it's still
very important here so what I do now is
that I can estimate the cardinality of
my partition using information
essentially the size of the typical
patterns to to the age divided by the
average size of the typical cell which
is 2 to the conditional entropy age X
given 3 so this is the cardinality of
the partition so now we plug so ganado
the partition again is this 1 to 2 the
information because it's age X minus H
is given to the same reason it appears
in information theory but now it means
that the number of functions is 2 to the
2 to the information I have another
exponent now this is this is a tricky
with those not terribly surprising when
you think about it I get this type of
bound the bound is now that generation
error is bounded by the exponent of the
mutual information between my
representation and it should layers
divided by number of examples which
means that any bit of compression of the
representation is equivalent to doubling
the data this is exponential improvement
in the bound so essentially if I
compress as the layers seem to be doing
in this phase of compression I actually
compress the representation by K beats
it's like doubling multiplying my data
by 2 to the side of my data by 2 to the
K ok so I argued that this bounds much
more realistic
if you actually look at the value of the
information of course those of you who
are a little more familiar with planning
Theory know that so essentially this
bount become interesting when the
information is essentially a bill of the
order of the log of the sample size
now the log of the sample size is
precisely the minimum number of samples
which I really need to label if I could
choose them carefully this is the
minimal number of queries so rather than
having randomly label example I could if
I choose the labels I could settle for
this log M and this is precisely the
classical sample complexity example
compression results of mantra BrahMos
and few others from the 80s so we know
this is not really surprising what is
surprising is that the network is
actually minimizing this information and
this is happening through diffusion so
okay so now I move to the last part of
the story
well actually it says the second part of
story so okay so I hope I convinced you
that this information plan is
interesting first of all you see there
interesting dynamics things concentrate
somehow in a very nice way so the
question is what is the bound the
maximal value of compression that I can
achieve for a certain number of bits of
information so this turned out to be a
question we asked a long time ago in the
as I asked it in the context of
understanding what is the minimum
sufficient statistic the middle
sufficient statistic is as you may know
is the simplest fashion compact function
of a sample and that capture all the
information about the parameter of a
distributor this is the classical
definition if we don't think about the
parameter we think about the label is
the thing we care about so if I want to
compress my data without losing
information about the label and the way
we do it is essentially by solving a
constrained variational problem minimize
the mutual information between X and the
representation which in this case I call
X hat because this is the notion use the
information theory and radiation theory
it's just a coincidence and and from
minimize the information to the
representation subject to constrain on
the information on the label now this
looks like a tricky problem it's
actually solvable and we solve it by
essentially an extension of what we call
the blot or Emoto algorithm
theory or essentially it's it's it's an
iteration between the L colder and the
decoder alternately and this iteration
converged we know how to prove it almost
always except some very important
critical points on the on the curve and
they give you this interesting limit so
essentially there is in this plan
information about the output information
about the input there is a line this
black line which is the rate distortion
like function which tells you above this
line that no representation whatsoever
below this line that many and the
optimal representation are exactly
sitting on this line now this if I have
all the data so in principle not our
first intuition was this is something we
wrote in 2015 is that if nothing else
stops the network the layers should
somehow converge to this line there was
absolutely no reason for saying there
but but I said okay if they work so well
maybe their optimal in this information
theoretic sense now notice that this is
precisely the boundary was talking about
this is a distribution dependent I mean
problem dependent bound but the bound is
universal for any architecture whether
it's your computer or your brain or an
alien from another galaxy
nobody can do better than this bound
okay so this is the absolute absolute
bound on this problem now the real
problem that I really always need to
emphasize is that you don't have an
infinite data unfortunately we always
have a finite sample and if you have a
finite sample we actually cannot reach
this this black line we reach a very
different bound which is this red line
which means if I'm using a very little
compression a very fine partition of my
data I will not generalize because most
of the cell would be empty
I will not see enough labels to actually
fill myself so in this case I'm going to
get a very poor prediction of my label
from very fine partition on the other if
I compress too much then the black line
hits me and I simply cannot generalize
so there is some maximum somewhere here
where where I want to be with finite
samples this is the best you can achieve
this finite amount of data and this is
the rigorous bounded we know how to
calculate again only from the problem
and the number of random examples
nothing else comes into the screen so so
the argument is that indeed the network
are somehow fitting this pushing the
last layer into this region now in these
pictures like highly exaggerated I mean
in real in reality that the black line
is a lot closer to the to the line but
it's still there and the red line
depends of course on the sample size so
there are two type of losses we need to
to work on one is that what I call the
compression loss due to the fact that
actually compressed representation which
is this the first part and then there's
the finite sample loss which is the
difference in the red and the end and
the end and the black and I want to
minimize both of them okay so now
without so here is just just to give you
a flavor what happens when you train
with finite data so it's the same
problem the same put all small network
but again I argue that this is the
general picture we see it in all
problems on the right you see training
with a lot of data in this case eighty
percent of the data this one so you see
again there is this trajectories of the
layers remember I'm talking about
information plane information or a
perversion output and you see this very
fast convergence to this green line
which is what I call the inflection
point where there's a sharp transition
and the behavior of the gradient so in a
minute and then you see that there is
this slow convergence see that all the
layers shift to the left and you see
this by the number of epochs here is the
color and you see that the color is
yellow for very high number of epochs
and it's blue for very small number of
epochs and you see that indeed they
slowly converge to some points on the
other hand if you train them with small
data it's only 5% of the data you get
the same initial phase they fit the data
very well but then the information
through the compression goes down so
this is something which we may call
overfitting
it's not obvious we think it's actually
over compression I mean you're
simplifying your presentation beyond
what you are actually allowed to do by
the data to her given so you cannot keep
the homogeneity of the cells respect to
the labels because not have enough data
okay
so and this is somewhere in between is
somewhere in between so of course the
nice
the nice thing is that we actually have
a theory for this line and the theory is
again data dependent but model
independent okay so just to understand
what happens look at the same video
again but this time at the bottom I show
you the the training error
I'll show you generalization error but
does method they look very similar and
you see that the first phase was
essentially changed exactly when the
error got into this me where it's
essentially saturated so of course when
that error becomes more or less constant
it's still going down but it's very
slowly going down you see that the
gradients are going to be smaller
because the oils more but now the
mini-batches the difference between the
training of some examples another
examples of these fluctuations start to
dominate the story and indeed this is
the picture I really like to show so
what you see here this is actually the
network we used we used but as I said
this is not it's important only in one
aspect that the layers get as the width
of the layers gets smaller and smaller
so this sort of an Eiffel Tower if I use
the different architecture I'm going to
see a different different type of
behavior in the plan but the gist of it
is that the last layer is doing
something very very similar so so so
what you see here in different colors
the the mean of the gradients I mean
those solid lines and the broken line
are the standard deviation of the
gradient pair weights in every one of
the layers and what I want to emphasize
and actually turns out that we are not
the first to see this so this is well
established that there are actually two
phases to clear phases of the training
in the first one you see that the
gradient is much larger than the
standard deviation this is what
engineers like to call high
signal-to-noise ratio this by the way is
a log log plot so the difference in log
is the rate log of the ratio so this is
a log signal-to-noise ratio now so in
the first phase is essentially two order
of magnitude difference between the
fluctuations and the mean this is what
we call clean credit okay on the other
end when they reach this this gray line
around 300 epochs the as I said the
gradient essentially saturate
it's not exactly saturated but it get to
be very small so the Graduate the norm
of the gradient is actually the norm of
the gradient in every layers squared and
and and you get and you get a that the
gradient slow I get down there so those
are the source of dispersion among the
layers there the lower layers get a
larger gradient and then the smaller
gradient and then them
the highlight of em are dead but what is
really dramatic is that the variance
jumps and from this point on essentially
the standard deviation is much larger
than the mean so this is what you all
call low signal generalization which
means a very noisy gradient so so
there's like a very clear and an analogy
dual picture of the same story that we
saw with information in the gradients
actually I think that the I know that
the gradients determined the picture
actually actually solve a Fokker Planck
equation using those gradients you know
that the propagates back to a Rayleigh
distribution and show you that
information indeed does it so but notice
what happens here there are actually two
phases one of them is also called drift
so those of you who know what the fork
of my equation is the Pokemon equation
is a linear term which is governed
governing the drape and has a
quadratical second derivative term which
is governed by the fixations if the
linear time is larger essentially you
just move and the distribution does move
linearly if the second term is larger
during a diffusion equation much larger
so you essentially dominated by
diffusion and it turns out that if my
story is correct that the diffusion
phase of the gradient is the most
important part of the learning and you
see that there is the diffusion phase
actually have many many details that I
can see in this in this picture for
example this peak is related to the fall
into a very flat minima and and and and
the fact that the difference between the
variance and the mean in log scale is
essentially constant telling is telling
me that the log signal-to-noise ratio of
the gradient is essentially constant
when I approach the convergence which is
completely consistent with the Gaussian
bound on the information because the log
of the one to signal-to-noise ratio is
the Gaussian bound on the mutual
information so there's a beautiful
confirmation or reassurance of the whole
story just coming from the gradients
actually what we do now is really
solving the fokker-planck equation
the first two moments of the
distribution using the fokker-planck
equation and we see exactly the same
story without measuring information at
all to talk about it by the way so so
the story now the king began becomes a
little clearer
there are two phases to the gradient
here you see the signal-to-noise ratio
on the left here so the second Arizona
has this very sharp drop it's not only a
phase condition is some sort of a
crossover and and and and in this low
phase gradients are very noisy and this
- is great are very clean in the gray
phase I essentially fit the labels in
the slow phase I essentially learn to
forget the irrelevant details of the
problem so this is some sort of an
unsupervised learning I mean because
nobody as isolate is labeling the
background but the fact that I see some
pictures with this background something
other picture with another background is
giving me a lot of information on what
to ignore because there are fluctuations
in the mini-batches
and by the way if you change the size of
the mini batch you see that these two
points they the point where you you
start to forget I mean this point is is
exactly linearly related to the phase
transition in the gardens so any any
actually but even when you train with
the full batch I mean you and some
people do I mean let's say that I don't
want many batches so this is actually
done in another attempt to to show this
be wrong and you train it with with full
batch and you get compression as well
but so if we do it with full batch you
see that the full batch is somewhere
along this line it's just a much much
slower compression and indeed even with
full batch there's noise there's
quantization noise in time there is a
noise due to all sorts of sampling error
and so on so this small noise is enough
to eventually compress the plantation
now okay so we see this in many problems
and and I just want to skip it because
we don't have time
the the gist of it again I'm using this
tool to often
surprisingly or not the layers in this
problem converge to the optimal bound so
what you see here in blue
is the information button the curve
which I calculate using rate distortion
using the blotter Emoto algorithm
because I know the distribution of the
problem and what you see in red those
crosses the endpoint of the layers in
this plan and of course we magnified
everything this is just the region
between 0.99 to 1 so everything is just
blow-up of the top of the curve but this
is this is beautiful because indeed it
turns out that those layers form some
sort of what we call a successively
refine durable code of the problem say
and and and and now it's entirely
different story and why it happens okay
so why it happens I'll give you just the
the again they they're very sketchy
proof of it okay so we know I mean what
what what is it in in in the stochastic
dynamics it actually put you to optimal
compression this is not something we
used to have an information theory I
mean nobody as far as I know is composed
are many random codes all over the place
but nobody is using noise I mean random
walks I mean diffusion processes in
order to compress maybe you should so so
if you look at that what actually
happens again in a very sketchy way
there is a lunch of in dynamics which
means the weight as a function exact the
time derivative of the weights is
proportional to minus the gradient of
the error but it's not a clean arrow
there's some noise added to it and the
noise is exactly due to those many
batches so this is a gradient descent or
a gradient flow with noise and we know
that you know for a long time now that
this under some conditions which convex
which are not true here like convex a
energy surface of things like this and
your converge to a gift distribution
adventure or to a maximum entropy
distribution so so the stationary
distribution of this dynamics is
exponential in the training err so this
is known since the twenties
hundred years sooner now a this is that
usually the convergence is very fast if
you are indeed in a convex space but you
are not in a convex place forget it so
actually they are they think about a
very high dimensional space where only
few of the
irrelevant just thought that features
actually changed the label think about
our face recognition so I know yeah I
know they distantly in the eyes and the
size of the nose and so if you are the
very twenty features that you can these
are the relevant dimensions and all the
other million dimensions of the network
are essentially irrelevant so what if
you think about the covariance matrix of
the noise it's going to be extremely
elongated very small in the relevant
dimension is very and very wide in the
area of the dimensions now is it good or
bad it's actually good because what
happens at you is very quickly
converging the relevant dimension of the
problem and you stay there this happens
in the drift phase but then in the in
the diffuser phase they essentially do a
random walk in all the irrelevant
dimensions this random walk is
increasing the entropy of the irrelevant
parameters by and I do it in every one
of the million dimension of the problem
so the fact that each one of them is
just like one random walk is is average
with the fact that another one is doing
another random walk so on average you
actually get this gives distribution in
the irrelevant dimensions and as you
know the dynamics of diffusion I'm sure
you all know that diffusion grows like a
Gaussian where the width grows like the
square root of time okay in flat space
okay so this is what we all learned in
school in elementary school I think that
the diffusion grows like a square root
of time and there and essentially this
tells us that the time that it takes to
grow the entropy is exponential in the
entropy because I forgot to tell you
that the entropy of a Gaussian is the
log of the stun duration so entropy
grows like square root of time but like
log of square root of time and time
grows like exponent of the entropy so
this turns out to be quite interesting
because this gives us a completely new
understanding of why the layers help you
and I'm going to finish with this it's
one hour and five minutes I was told
that I have 75 minutes okay so
essentially this is really a beautiful
picture you like it so it's the same
problem the same specific network that
I'm playing with all the time but again
this is not specifically this problem I
trained it once with one hidden layer on
the top top left and then two hidden
layers three hidden layers and so on
until you get to five or six hidden
layers and the remarkable thing about
this is that when you look at the colors
okay remember yellow is ten thousand
epochs a lot of time and blue purple is
very short time so we saw that is the
first layer this one one hidden layer
you see that he takes essentially
forever I mean within 10,000 efforts I
didn't converge to a good solution it's
a very simple Network I know it can
learn the problem the problem can be
learned was one hidden layer takes take
a very long time now when I start to
increase the network move to six hidden
layers a lot more parameters and lost
not complicated but you see this all
down in the purple essentially very
quickly within a few hundred epochs I
converts to very good solution good
solution means high information about
the label so surprising or contra
intuitively the larger the network the
faster the convergence okay so no this
is the experiment I mean these are just
the theory has to come now okay so what
this is what we see in simulations
actually so this is a small problem you
can actually compare these things so
there is some advantage to having many
layers and most of the advantages in
this diffusion process because we all we
see that we get very quickly even with
one even layer to the point of
compression and then it starts to slow
okay so let's think again about
diffusion so I told you that diffusion
is actually a Langevin process I mean no
adding noise and I converge to this
distribution but think about I just told
you that essentially increasing the
entropy of the width the width of a line
increased the width of the distribution
in the irrelevant variable the second
show you varrick's
specifically you decrease the
signal-to-noise ratio of the relevant
irrelevant variables which means that
you forget them
you don't transfer the information the
capacity of the area of a viable is this
decreased this is just a Gaussian bound
on the on the capacity so so how long
does it take to it should actually
increase this this entropy so we know
that delta T is exponential in time
that's what I told you before so for
this flecked irrelevant variables the
increase of entropy is very slow I mean
it takes exponential time in every bit
of compression okay so this will take
forever to compress ten bits or
something yeah but imagine now that I
put in this this strain of a Markov
chain and all of the layers are doing
parallel diffusion because that's what I
do I add noise to all of them so they
start to push each other so instead of
having time which is exponentially in
the some of those compression but the
compression is the difference in
information between layer to layer I
moved to the maximum actually of those
turns which is larger than the sum so
this means that there is some sort of a
boost of compression because all of them
move together they really help each
other compressing so there is some sort
of enormous like a train with a lot of
engines the first moves faster it's no
it's not a good analogy bits a lot more
in just a linear increase its
exponential increase in time because I
move from an exponent of a sum to a sum
of exponents or actually the maximum of
those exponents so this is my really
very intuitive and very rough picture at
this point of why the layers help you
during this diffusion they actually
enhance the diffusion and each each
layer only have to compress from the
point that the previous one forgot
already of course this is not exactly
true because you see that the layers the
first layers don't forget everything for
it only part of the story okay so so the
next part of the story which I am only
going to to sketch and just so the
interesting question is now okay so we
understand quite a lot already we know
that it's the noise in the gradients
which is doing the work for us
we know that it's doing it because it
managed to D correlate the and the
irrelevant variables of the problem from
the label
this is a slow process because nobody's
labeling it for us so it happens because
there are fluctuations batch to batch
fluctuations because their variant
there's a variance in the background the
problem the next question is what
governs the convergence of the layers
were where do they converge to this into
B so this is actually where the layers
end up in this flan but not of the
function of the epochs but actually the
function of the number of examples and
you see that it's remarkably consistent
so now we have I have a completely
different story to tell which I'm not
going to do what governs the location of
the layers in this plane it has to do
with the structure of the problem itself
because now we have new map deep
learning into information theory and now
we can use information theory to
actually calculate things for example if
there is symmetry in the problem we can
show that the symmetric problem can
learn faster because the structure of
this landscape this energy landscape is
much simpler what I want to show you
just to end and end the top with a
direct simulation actually looking
inside those layers using what we call
the dimensional scaling I'm taking this
10 dimensional or 20 dimensional layer
and project it to two dimension and I
run all the 4,000 inputs and mark the
points in two dimensions and if if the
label of the output is is is one is I
mark it with black and if the label of
the output is is zero I mark it red and
if it's somewhere in between we market
somewhere in between these colors so
essentially what I want to service the
dynamics of the topology of the network
so this is the the first hidden layer
and remember in order for my theory to
make sense
I need those partitions to be
homogeneous respect to the label at some
point and notice that again so you
really see this really crystallization I
mean red attracts red and black attracts
red and eventually you get this this you
know pepper-and-salt picture of clusters
that some of them are red and some of
them are black and you see that the
colors became strong which means that
indeed those clusters those partitions
become more homogeneous and this is only
a two-dimensional projection so even in
to diminish
where can you see this but this is
highly non linearly separable if I want
to separate the black from the red here
I need to find a very funny and very
complicated curve even for this simple
problem now if I'm right this
representation of the layers should get
better and better when I move to higher
layers in terms of ability to decode the
label so okay so this is the first
hidden layer this is the fourth hidden
layer in this page in this in this
particular problem look what happened
during the same a box in the fourth
layer so again at the beginning there is
a strong bias to black I mean the offset
is not yet set and so on but eventually
even in the student master scaling you
see that the red goes in one side and
the black goes in another side but you
see something else which is quite
remarkable you see this dimensionality
collapse you see that eventually the
manifold on which the layer lies is some
low dimensional manifold which is highly
convoluted and highly folded in this
space but this is precisely this
relevant dimension which in this case is
one dimensional so you see that after
enough training the higher layers really
represent this low dimensional occurred
manifold of relevant variables and all
the environment variable disappeared
they were forgotten and so if you wait
long enough you you really see red
separated from black very nicely again
it's a highly nonlinear but I can still
almost separate them completely by one
line and you see this collapse of
dimensionality eventually the manifold
goes to one dimensional so I actually
believe that this is the picture in
general I mean and actually that many
and we can it's hard to see in high
dimension how to visualize an animation
but indeed what happens is that the
irrelevant dimensions are disappeared
because they added variants to the
gradients okay so I have a lot of other
things to say but I think I'll stop here
so essentially I argue that this
information plane picture gives you
really not only nice visualization which
is unique it's some sort of an x-ray of
the of the network it's also we are
giving us a lot of insight to understand
what's actually going on
when you combine it with them actually
this summer is somewhat oh it's a if I
combine it with the picture of the
gradients I get this very consistent
picture and that there's a first drift
phase which is very fitting the label
and then a noisy phase with the
essentially consistent with we're moving
be irrelevant variables and the
reduction of the dimensionality because
all the irrelevant dimensions eventually
don't pass through the layers and remain
irrelevant now there are many many
interesting questions has come out of
this analysis I mentioned some already I
mean okay so can you predict and the
location of the lay layers yes in some
cases we can in the cases where there is
an exact symmetry underneath and
actually all the problem I was actually
using was I chose it very carefully to
have an explicit oh three symmetry so
these are points on the sphere and the
label depends on some ratio of the
deeper type of the quadrupole moments so
those of you know some something about
the spherical harmonics in degrees this
is a invariant rotation and essentially
what I argue that the layers in this
case are going to collapse on
irreducible representations of the
symmetry that is a whole new theory
which really relates learning to atomic
physics if you want but it's very nice
on the other hand so this is directly
related to the structure of the
solutions on this information but on the
curl and I know that it is this your
this representation essentially water
feeling like the Gaussian channel water
feeling these are collapsed to load the
measure representation of the problem to
preserve information so this is just an
extension of the Gaussian channels and
Gaussian very distortion problems to
this so this is one the other thing is
what can you do with with for example
transfer learning I mean you want to
learn one problem and so I know already
that the lower layers represent fine
details of the problem usually they'll
learn local symmetries and the higher
layers are really those global features
you see it's very nicely here because
you see it was level of information they
actually remember the problem this has
something to do with okay I want to move
from one to the other I want to learn
from on data about another data
it tells it also has some very poor very
bad message to neuroscience at least if
you believe that this has anything to do
with neuroscience is that neurons but
it's individual neurons actually tell
you nothing actually so I don't believe
all these stories that you find in deep
learning you know if a cell or a castle
or an ISIL or whatever this is
completely anecdotal
I mean it's highly sensitive to the
architecture of course if using
convolution neural networks and you
constrain the receptive fields and you
do also to other things then this
scrambling of the layers disappear but
with fully connected methodologies but
we actually have a complete theory of
what do these layers really represent
and it has to do again with the
structure of the face transitions of the
program but this is another talk ok so
I'll stop here thank you very much
[Applause]
just a little bit of information is the
graduating assented us I mean the fact
that you use stochastic gradient descent
I mean you you a noisy version of the
gradient of the empirical laws so first
of all empirical laws the false if you
do use it actually the cross-entropy
laws or the log laws and which is
essentially mutual information but
that's that's the site okay but but
because you're using stochastic gradient
descent you get these two phases of
gradients okay this is has nothing to do
with mutual information okay you get
that you very quickly reduce the error
on the labels and then very slowly when
the error in the level essentially
saturates it's these noise in the
gradients which all people think is
random it's not random at all it's
actually very informative now what I'm
telling you okay this is stochastic
where this descent has nothing to do
information I didn't need information to
tell you that but now I look at what
Socastee gradients actually do I look at
the dynamics of diffusion and the
dynamic of diffusion using physics it's
pushing us to maximum entropy
distributions is losing information so
surprisingly it's the dynamic of the
stochastic gradient descent which is
decreasing the information so okay so
that's the connection between gradient
descent and information on the other
hand I showed you at the beginning of my
talk that reducing information is the
improving generalization so if I
actually compress the input by the way I
can compress the input by many different
other means for example adding nodes so
there's a very elegant working in
computer science a call of stability
bounds for example if you if your
problem is is stable to fluctuations in
the inputs then you generalize what you
think about its stability noise even if
I add some little noise to the input and
the label doesn't change
means that there is some sort of sphere
around my patterns with which sex to
which I mean violence a label is
invariant so this is compression but the
same is true about symmetry if the
Association symmetry rotation symmetry
anything like this it means that there
are always of some class of
transformations which to which the label
is invariant and this is the compression
bound which means that there is a group
of of patterns which I can put together
in one cell which will have the same
label so this is again by the same
argument the number of labels that you
need is not smaller it depends on you
and or which of this group and so on and
so forth I give you essentially any
generalization bound except those that
are what we call problems just wrongly
mixing like parity functions like
encrypted there I mean whenever you have
high sensitivity to noise in your input
you're not going to learn information
theory is not telling you that but
you're not going to learn because you
don't have this ability to compress the
representation if a single bit in your
in your inputs is going to change the
label forget it deep learning will not
learn it so it's not a direct connection
the connection is between the physics
and the dynamics of the problem and then
the miraculous fact that information
theory is telling you something about
typical behavior of large problems so
I'm using combining it's just like you
know entropy and energy tell us
something about the equilibrium state of
matter here it's not because the
molecules are calculate entropy is
because entropy is describing the
distribution for us it's not an
intrinsic properties it's a global so
it's the same story again it's not a
side effect this is the right
mathematics to think about it but it's
for the same reason exactly the same
rationale that molecules in this room
are very much very close to gives
distribution subsistence and temperature
and energies it's the same rational it's
not because the molecule calculate
entropy it's because this is the most
likely or maximum entropy state of the
system and that's what we are going to
find also something very similar I know
it's not easy to digest but think about
it more questions yes
[Music]
if you are working on writing a reverse
paper for information theory and this
hopefully you'll see it sooner but but
essentially what I'm saying here is that
these two numbers for the last hidden
layer which is essentially the point
where you managed to put your last layer
in this plan is telling you both the
generalization error which is how much
information you have about Y and the
number of examples that you use because
you are converged to essentially it's
it's this maximum of the red curve that
is shown so that's the argument so
because the the maximum of this red the
compression is dominated is dominating
the generation error I think I more or
less argue let and in the information
about the level is done anything I'm
sorry the compression is dominating the
number of examples the sample complexity
and the information about the label is
dominating the is bounding the
information the generation error so it's
these two numbers that really give you
the whole trade-off now the best rate of
this you can achieve is determined by
the optimal by the information base on a
curve which is essentially what is the
most compression that you can get is a
certain amount of information but it it
stucks it at some point and this is the
interesting time and where it ends so
when you get to this particular value
you know that this is what you could do
with this number for examples the
infinite number of replicas this is a
convergence plan if so you converge to a
point look at the network so if you look
at one of those networks I mean I don't
know where for example those I showed
you here so it's the last point this one
here or this one here
get the two numbers here the number of
bits here and the number of bits here
look at how much you compressed their
presentation and this tells me what is
going to be generalization error and
what was the number of examples that you
had to use in order to get there yeah I
know I know it's not it's not formulated
precise enough and and but this is the
intuition
yeah I'm sorry I you get into the the
nasty question session sorry please ask
me everything you want this yes what
happens if you go to I mean this was a
canonical example the time runs through
this paper but but we train with tried
it with different number of lis so the
real question is what if I'm right that
essentially the number of layers is
improving exponentially the convergence
of use infinite number of layers so this
is obviously wrong first of all you pay
computationally heavily with this I mean
there are many more promises and then
and then in order for this to make sense
I need I need enough space between the
layers that they take actually move and
if you just use too many layers they're
going to be redundant I mean most of
them about to have exactly the same
please actually see it here I mean there
are six layers but you actually see only
four or five and the sixth one is on top
of the first one so adding more layers
is not going to change the picture
dramatically the question is what does
change the picture dramatically and this
has to do with the with the face
structure of the problem so so if you
notice in in my information a button a
curve there are those blue lines which I
didn't mention those blue line has sub
optimal solutions of the prone which
means that there are different phases of
the topology of representation and this
is actually what I'm aiming it
so essentially you don't need more
layers than the number of different
phases anything beyond this will be
redundant I mean we do just another
layer which is I want to want to
summation on the previous one how do you
know they're not usually there are many
many sub optimal solutions unless you
have symmetry if the problem is special
or symmetric or simple then that those
those facial dishes those are those
those this sub of the solutions really
collapse to very few and that that's
when the simple actually works over so
our problem is symmetric and I believe
that this is why you see such many
pictures in general it's going to be a
mess I mean just to give you some
understanding what's going on there in
general those but this bifurcation
diagram is getting more complicated and
if if there is symmetry all those phase
transitions or splits of clusters happen
then in the same places this is actually
the phase diagram of this particular
problem but you see that it's enough to
put a layer between two major
transitions here so this is some sort of
connection between the the number of
layers is determined by the really
intrinsic structure of the Joint
Distribution of X and Y which is
determining the spaced additions just
say longer I can show you much more
about it but it's a very good question
okay so that's again a tricky question
so first of all I argued that the
mini-batches
enhance the performance significantly I
mean so you see again in this in this in
this picture that when you increase the
mini batch size you actually shift the
transition point because the noise is
smaller so what what comes out of it is
another interesting consequence or you
know prediction of the theory is that
the best mini batch size should be such
that the covariance matrix of the
gradients due to the mini batches is
aligned nicely with the Hessian matrix
of the minimum because then you're
actually pushing it in there in the
right directions correctly I mean though
so these two ellipses thought ellipses
its ellipses in very high dimension
where they should be aligned if they
align then you are most efficient so
there is a prediction here now once you
take full bitumen you completely ignore
the many base
the noise becomes is there only from for
numerical reasons for for discoloration
of time and indeed the whole thing is
very very slow and if you see here I
mean even for this process if it is a
full bridge you already get to thousands
of iterations before you actually begin
to see the compression but eventually
there is compression due to numerical
noise it's just it's just not effective
so this is my prediction if you choose
the first of all land with a lot of
variability of the background this is
really important because this is what's
going to give you a better
stochasticity in the between the
mini-batches
which is going to eventually learn
better but now measure this variability
of the background actually did the
covariance of the of the of the of the
mini-batches gradients and match it to
the covariance of the pronin and science
in many cases we can actually do this
this will enhance the learning that's my
prediction this will be some sort of
matching between the noise and the
channel in some sense of this kind of
this process
[Applause]
you